we'd like to consider a system of
particles say we have object one we'll
call this the J table ject object and
and somewhere in the system of particles
is a center of mass now we know that the
external force is causing the momentum
of the system to change and what we now
like to show is that we can reduce this
system to an effective single particle
the way we'll do that is recall that the
momentum of the system is given by the
sum of the individual Momentum's we'll
call that the J the particle where we're
summing J from 1 to N and that's the sum
of the Momentum's of the various
particles now when you differentiate the
momentum of the system with respect to
time we're just differentiating the
velocity and so that becomes the
acceleration of the J the particle now
we saw when we define the center of mass
that the acceleration of the center of
mass times the total mass of the system
was equal to this sum of m j aj j goes
from 1 to n so we see that another way
to think about how the momentum the
system of particles is changing is
simply the total mass times the
acceleration of the center of mass and
our combination of newton's second and
third law now becomes that only the
external forces cause the momentum of
the system to change so that's equal to
the total mass times the acceleration of
the center of mass now what does this
equation really mean so let's draw our
pictures again here's our system we have
particles 1 etc that's the jave particle
and particles and in here is the center
of mass now I'm going to outline my
system like this
and what this equation is telling us is
that we can just focus by putting all of
the mass and total at the center of mass
and that center of mass is going to move
according to some trajectory and all we
have to think about is this is now a
simple this is a point particle of total
mass M M total so what we've done is
we've done in very important reduction
we've taken a complicated system of
particles and reduced it to a single
point particle of total mass M located
at C m and the dynamics of that total
particle is if there is an external
force acting on this system we place
this external force at the center of
mass and now we can calculate the
acceleration of the center of mass is
just that external force divided by the
total mass and that's how we can reduce
this complicated system of particles to
a translational motion of the center of
mass now we still cannot describe the
individual interactions in the system
but we're not trying to do that anymore
we're not trying to trace how each
particle moves we're just looking at as
our system as a point particle and
talking about how that point like object
is translating in space and this is a
powerful tool that we'll use again and
again and again